[Laughter]
did he have a sense of humor
um yeah i think he did but i think he
was really embarrassed and i felt bad he
didn't feel he didn't
i don't know that's a difference you
will play pranks for yourself and you
don't care who it's on people get mad
i do care when they get mad but in the
moment while i'm doing it i don't know
that they're going to be mad and i don't
know what to do when they're mad i say
i'm sorry and
lou has been the the the recipient of a
lot of these mine mine mine i wasn't
humiliated in front of the audience mine
was a strict thing between
you me and i guess the crew and i guess
rich
i was very young in my career i'd never
really done a theater before so
um
i'm on stage and you know when you're
that nervous and it's like
it's a it's also like an opportunity you
know i'm probably making
more than i usually make at the clubs
and
we roll into the theater
i guess i must have been at soundcheck
um
and
you know how he's a big star you know
like
this is a huge few thousand seat theater
and it's an off night it's like a monday
or something so you're filling a theater
on an off night and i go what's all this
do you have an orchestra and the stage
manager says no that's for the rest of
the week you know like carousel this
play here or whatever
show was guys and dolls was there so
there's a full orchestra behind a
curtain
and that the audience is never going to
see
it's not even ringing a bell
it's not even a funny story but i go on
stage
how can how can whatever
follows your reaction how could it not
be funny
the fact that it's not funny is making
me laugh because you can't even get it
because it also taught me something
about myself like keep calm and carry on
you know
i'm on stage
and i'm doing my act whatever the [ __ ] i
talked about back then right right
waffles new jersey you know
growing up in the cave just my little
cute like you know i wasn't the rose guy
i had no i had none of that
attack mode i was cute you were an
adorable little jew with a full head of
hair with a jufro that that would make
uh any uh any 70s basketball player
jealous and
every time i got a it was a reward every
time i got a laugh a big laugh which was
you know every couple minutes i'd get a
big laugh not constantly but when i got
a big laugh
so that the audience just was loud
right on the laugh
there'd be a
a huge gong noise right behind my head
do you remember this now no do you
remember it rich you know
it was you on the go well probably i did
not know that until right now
i assumed but
so every time i'm like punchline waffles
and the audience would roar and then
come
right behind my head so the gog is a
foot behind there's a curtain i'm in
front of a curtain and then a gong and
the audience doesn't hear the gong
because they're laughing on the left but
what they do see is me
me flinching like i'm about to get hit
without
every time there's a round of applause
you're like this
[Laughter]
so
i'm never killing this heart i've never
killed this hard because it's like this
big theater show but i'm also like
they're you know i don't know what you'd
call that like
you know like i turned into like wild
and crazy guy i'm not two guys walking
to a bar whoa
and
you know i have no idea because i didn't
even see the gong beforehand so i have
no idea of course i get off stage i walk
around the back and you guys are
standing there with a gong pushed up
against the girl
you just found a gong and it was a gong
there
is i learned i did a lot with lou too
the the the juxtaposition of being able
to be behind a curtain right behind the
comic without them knowing and to be
hide through the anonymity of a giant
laugh yeah was hysterical we did one and
it wasn't me which we had a comic also
opening for me
and right
on the setup in the middle of the setups
one of the guys one of the stage
managers would just stick his bare ass
out the out of the curtain so that he'd
be going you know
i'll tell you something i went on a date
and it was a first date she looks at me
and she says and then you'd hear the
audience go wow wow like it's singing
like but we did it the whole act and it
was off and he got upstairs i go how are
they he goes you know
they're responsive but they're weird
because they don't have a sense of
timing you're going to feel really off
out there
they do this weird thing and it's not
even like laughter it's just whoa
whoa this is gonna be good and i just
let him describe that to me and i always
felt like that was gonna be
[Music]
you